[Music]
we're gonna be talking today primarily
about Antos and more specifically GK on
Prem so quick intros my name is Weston
Hutchins I'm a product manager for GT on
Prem and I brought some fine folks with
me today you want to introduce yourself
sure
Kyle Bassett partner at Arctic been
working on anthems project for a while
closely with Wes since last year at neck
so excited to show you some of the stuff
we've been working on and and with Dan
and his team add up to even product
management at apt IVA and we've been
working with these guys on getting our
application to work on GKN print cool so
a lot of the sessions gonna be focused
on a real-world rollout so kind of a
mark tick went into opt IVA took a nap
they had and deployed it and we're gonna
cover sort of the the tips and tricks
and the the technical details of what
exactly GT on-prem is but before that I
want to just talk a little bit about
what problems we're trying to solve what
the vision for anthis is as we move on
and you know this really started from a
lot of customers that we were talking to
in gke like folks that were already in
cloud and they said we're doing our
modernization right now we have this we
have all these apps we're trying to move
them from VMs over to containers and
we're bought into a subset that can run
on the cloud but there's so many other
scenarios out there that we need to run
in physical data centers or in edge
locations so you know a common scenario
that I've heard is like oh we want to
cluster in every store or we want to
cluster at every oil site or we need to
have you know this workload running in a
particular region where we can't
necessarily move everything into the
cloud and the the message from that was
really we want to use kubernetes because
we've heard about all of these benefits
around portability and abstraction
kubernetes has really become the
standard for trying to make these
environments consistent but if you've
ever tried to take an off-the-shelf
distribution and get it up and running
yourself it just takes forever and I
think getting it installed is the easy
part what is really challenging for a
lot of customers
all the day to operations so having
having scale it out masters making sure
that you can do security patches doing
disaster recovery and backups and these
were all the features that we gave out
of the box with gke so these customers
were like well you know let's see if we
can bring gke on-prem and build this
package software that we can deploy in
these sites and that was the sort of the
beginning of our journey for anthos but
it's much the thing I want you guys to
leave with this this is really much more
than just kubernetes we use kubernetes
as that base abstraction layer to have a
portable environment but as Kelsey says
this is really the the start of what
will hopefully be a bunch of
higher-level tools that can run on this
platform and I like to describe the
building and building blocks of anthos
as primarily three open-source
technologies kubernetes for the
infrastructure pieces it's do for the
security management service management
stuff and then finally at the top Kay
native cloud run type of environments
where you can have that developer
tooling experience or you're devs don't
have to work directly with like
kubernetes llamó
or go into the details of configuring us
to do traffic splitting they can just
work with higher level constructs uh and
the thing that we've really done to mmm
to kind of build out anthos and figure
out how this thing is going to run is we
want to take the deployment and have it
running these different sites but the
the real power and what I like to call
sort of the brain that powers all of
these different locations of kubernetes
stok native in these other pieces is
this ant those hybrid control plan this
is the stuff that runs on Google cloud
platform and the the vision here is that
we have a single pane of glass we have a
single hosted service that you can use
to programmatically control clusters
running in these different sites and as
we get into the demo later on you'll get
to see how we've kind of done this
between gke and GT on Prem where you can
start to use the same tools the same
workflows all in the cloud and have that
going federated to the various locations
the the real personas the real people
that we really want to try and target
with this is you know in in a big
enterprise organization which you know I
imagine many of you are in there's all
these different specialty roles and
the the key value prop of anthos is
really making sure that we have the
right building blocks and the right
tools for each one of them we've sort of
already talked about the kubernetes
layer where we can take the the things
for jika on-prem put them on your
existing hardware running on top of
VMware and keep those consistent the sto
pieces or the cloud the cloud service
mesh pieces are really there for your
net up your sec ops people those are the
ones that want increased observability
better secure connections in between
services and more control over what's
going on in your environment and then
the developer experience so we want to
make sure to have a nice easy set of
building blocks for having
platform-as-a-service type features so
that you're devs can just push code and
have it deploy to the various clusters
now anthos like I said is a much bigger
effort what I want to talk about
specifically in this presentation is GK
on Prem so this is the footprint where
we take GK and we stall it on install it
on top of your stack and before we get
into the details I want a Dan to
introduce opt Eva a little bit and give
you an idea of what his use case was for
this particular proof of concept so I
may get a bit challenged here and have
to do two things at once two different
hands so I'm Dan downer like said I run
product management Activa we are a
business support company that runs
charging systems for some of the larger
telecoms in the world we have over a
hundred customers deployed eighty
countries do three billion plus
transactions the main product that we're
going to talk about today what we did
that prototype with the proof-of-concept
is what we call the opt Eva charging
engine
it's a Tier one charging integer that
means the this is built for the biggest
telecom companies in the world it does
primarily raiding and charging it's got
quite a bit of functionality in terms of
how you customize it how you can build
it specifically for your environment
what it integrates with but the big
things here you should think about is
that this is a mission critical
application for telecom companies if
this doesn't work they're billing system
doesn't work and they don't make any
money so
important from their perspective that
it's it scales that it runs at a high
level of reliability and that it can
operate efficiently so this is kind of
the the overall stack essentially if you
look at the the dark blue piece there
that's the piece that we're going to
focus on it's part of a bigger system so
it has to fit into their entire
environment one of the things that a lot
of people don't quite internalize is
they start to try to take an enterprise
application and move it into more of a
cloud native or kubernetes environment
is that it's not just take your app
break it up maybe a little bit maybe not
shove it over into something like a VM
like you would have traditionally and
then run it there's a decent amount of
work that needs to be done here in terms
of modifying your application so it's
really important that you think about
how you're gonna containerize and take
advantage of some of the specific cloud
native applications and technologies out
there it's a good opportunity to
actually spend some time looking at how
you can simplify as you simplify your
app it's also important to think about
some of the benefits that you're trying
to get out of this and invest in those
such as the scaling and the automated
deployment update so if you look at the
diagram on the left there you know
that's your typical virtualization model
as we moved into a cloud native
kubernetes based deployment some of the
things that we really focused on like I
said first of all is you really got to
think about how you're gonna change the
the architecture of your application to
take advantage of a lot of the cloud
native patterns that's critical both
from the perspective of how your
applications gonna behave but also how
you're gonna be able to efficiently
operate and and deploy it a lot of
legacy applications are using a bunch of
proprietary technology this is also an
opportunity for you to go out and start
looking at using open source tools like
you know typically like for example we
moved a lot of our proprietary
monitoring tools over to the elk stack
and then leveraging some things like
stackdriver and things like that key to
the delivery of this is our ability to
actually improve our scalability and our
operational efficiency so
if all we did was take this thing and
move it to the cloud or move it to a
private cloud and we didn't get a whole
lot of benefit out of it that was an
interesting exercise but you know why
did we do it so it's really critical
that you think about what you're trying
to achieve out of this you know what are
your goals in terms of your and and the
SLA your end operational efficiency
whether you're trying to achieve higher
reliability or a lower TCO those are all
things that you need to think about in
advance and we spent quite a bit of time
looking at that in any enterprise
environment but especially in telecom
you know it's it's relatively
conservative people are not willing to
bet the farm on some new technology
right away so it's important that you
give people a incremental step through
their their options so that they can
actually feel like they could take the
jumps as they need to as they're ready
to and that their business is able to
adapt so you know on the on a typical
legacy environment you're sitting there
with a pretty rigid environment you have
to pre provision everything there's a
high cost as we move into the kubernetes
on-prem kind of scenario we get a much
better flexibility in terms of our
deployment options you can leverage bare
metal and a bright of private clouds to
do that the next step really when you
think about moving this if you're going
to do it incrementally is to start to
split out some of your systems and run
that in a hybrid scenario and then
finally you if you're trying to make
this journey you move all the way to the
public cloud and everything is running
on a managed service in the cloud and
that where is where from our perspective
you get the most TCO benefit you get the
most efficiency you take an advantage of
the all the reasons why Google cloud
exists the end state the you know the
state of Nirvana if you want to call it
in terms of from the provider side of
things is that we can deploy pretty much
the same application with small amounts
of differences whether it's in the
public cloud private cloud you know that
allows us to be much more efficient it
also allows us to
the same code it allows people to
migrate easily the hybrid story or the
public cloud story becomes much better
when you do that and so that's really
the promise that we see with GK on Prem
is that if you look at this diagram you
know besides some of our storage and
database managed services that we're
trying to use in the cloud we can pretty
much end up with the same application
and as you'll see with a proof of
concept that's where we ended up cool
so before I hand it over to Kyle I want
to give at least some context settings
so I'm like how does GK on-prem work
from an architecture perspective so you
get the bits for GK and Prem and how
this comes packaged is you get an admin
OVA workstation this is just a tool you
can spin up on a VM in your VMware
environment that you can use to
bootstrap the rest of your cluster so
the first thing you do is you run
prepare this runs some pre validations
checks we've added support for
downloading container images to things
like private registries for folks that
have offline and air gapped installs
we've also added support during the
install process for things like static
IP allocation for folks that don't have
DHCP set up in those environments but
the the end state is that you end up
with this this single long live node
called an admin control plan and this is
really the orchestrator for all of the
on Prem clusters all of the commands
that you're going to be using interact
with this admin control plan and for
instance if you want to create new
clusters we've called them user clusters
in this example you go in and run a
create cluster command and go and spin
up these different environments so right
now we do have a separate utility from G
cloud over time I think you'll start to
see G cloud our CLI merge with some of
these commands so that we can invoke
invoke these from from a single
environment but for now we've just built
a nice lightweight CLI package in order
to spin up these new clusters the once
you have all of your clusters spun up or
just even a single cluster the next step
is registering this cluster with our
cloud console and this is the piece
where we can start to do more of the
single pane of glass and also the remote
management of G key on Prem so you walk
through a simple flow in our cloud
console the things that it will ask you
for is do
some metadata exchange and then some
credentials to access that cluster after
you go and connect like one of the
pieces that gets downloaded is this
lightweight connection agent this thing
sits next to your API server and allows
us to go from the cloud console and
reach into that API server an issue of
cube cube protocol man's one of the nice
things about this is that every
authentication flow for this happens as
the end-user credential so if your
developers want to use this they will
only see things that they are
authenticated to see even for these on
Prem clusters so if there are certain
namespaces that they only have
visibility to those will only show up
the only those names faces will show up
for them inside the console now the
probably the number one question we get
is around this external connectivity
like what is this how does it work this
is really we wanted something that was
nice quick and easy out-of-the-box
experience so the GK connect agent is is
really a lightweight G RPC proxy that we
can use to access these API servers and
running in these various environments no
VPN is needed no direct interconnect to
get these things set up and you have a
secure connection to the control plan
this really is just for control plain
data so this is not like a replacing a
fat pipe of monitoring telemetry and all
that stuff they have their own data data
pipeline data path things but this
really gives us the ability to have that
single pane of glass experience for all
of the different environments we're
gonna talk a lot more about networking
and storage a bit later but we wanted to
do it as part of the demo so you could
actually see it working in real time
so with that Kyle over to you all right
so um we decided we're gonna give a
pretty in-depth demo original plan was
to do a live demo but there's a lot to
cover so I thought it'd be better if we
covered it all and we're gonna have more
of an open discussion and and give you
some opinions on what we put together
the opt IVA app is a pretty cool app
they've done a good job making it cloud
native and it runs in a gke today so
much of the exercise of what we wanted
to do as far as goals was develop a lot
of knowledge around it and prove that we
could port this application in a short
period of time over to GK on Prem
and also just get something working and
and then start to scale test it and
start to do all the resiliency things
that we wanted to do so we're pretty
pleasantly surprised with how quick we
got it up and working with Dan teams we
got through it pretty quickly so we'll
dive into the details and I know a lot
of people haven't seen it at all so
we're gonna try to show what it looks
like we did this in five weeks so we had
a pretty aggressive timeline that is
everything from getting the servers that
we used racked and stacked and getting
ESX on them deploying all the base
components op Teva leverages cloud build
and GCR and the cloud today so we wanted
to be able to leverage that process and
that CI process and pull the images down
locally and then be able to deploy them
everything was done in helm templates so
that made it a lot easier for us to
deploy and get things up but we also
needed things like persistent storage
that we're gonna get into and talk about
those aspects and week four was really
about let's start to throw some load at
this and let's see if the scalability
components that op Teva has in their
application can we scale pods can we
scale nodes on the backend we really
beat up on the cluster pretty good so we
had to get another node added this week
to be able to actually test some of the
scaling components and we wrapped up
with documentation and making sure
everybody knew what was going on it
slides not really painting properly for
some reason but it was a pretty cool
project that is a map of the world just
picture it and we were 100% remote none
of us had met in person up to you has a
very distributed team of experts around
that are very skilled so we did this all
over slack Google Hangouts collaboration
tools so it just goes to show you don't
need the card pass to go into a data
center to build a private cloud anymore
you can do it completely remotely so
that was a pretty cool project to see it
be completely distributed so I guess
we're gonna dive over to the demo yeah
well one of the things I wanted to see
in the previous slide is just you know
we packaged some stuff out of the box
with GQ in print you get things like
monitoring you get away DC connections
through
identity providers but you know what Eva
had a lot of existing tools and
technologies like sista and harbor and
vaults and stuff like that
and then as part of the concept like
Kyle went in there and plumbed those
into the system which will show right
now so you can take your existing stack
and integrate those into GQ and Prem
yeah I think the main point with this is
really it was just another region for us
to deploy to in the end we were able to
use a lot of the same tools and
techniques a few changes obviously
around storage and networking which
we're gonna get into but it really just
looks like another deployment target for
up Teva today which is really what as
dan talked about is was really the
ultimate goal so we'll flip over to the
demo so we're gonna go through a bunch
of different components here and I think
we'll all have will have a few comments
to say around them we're gonna start at
what what this looks like at the at the
very least of it so I've created some
aliases in this demo so you're gonna see
a is your cube CTL but it's pointing at
the admin cluster so the the part Wes
talked about the advantages the
environment and can bootstrap additional
clusters you as the user cluster user
cluster is where we put all the Optio
applications and all the pods and all
the supporting infrastructure are gonna
see some namespaces so if we look at the
admin cluster so you know you recognize
these type of namespaces in a regular
kubernetes cluster if we look at the
user cluster you see things like GK
Connect that Wes talked about you see
Harbour you see sto so and the OCE
pieces are the Optio application so
that's where we put all of the pods that
went into there if you look at nodes the
admin cluster is fairly small multi
master support is coming in the in the
release that's dropping very soon and
then if you look at our bottom cluster
we have 11 nodes so essentially these
are 11 worker nodes that are able to
process load and we've done some scaling
up and scaling down that's why you see
one of them is a little bit shorter time
we we've got this demo put together
yesterday so you're probably wondering
what it looks like in B Center it looks
just like any of your other classes any
of your other V Center environments
there's nothing really special about it
we started with a clean cluster we
obviously need
to be able to call the API ogk on-prem
is fully orchestrated all he vm
provisioning provisioning you're really
not having to go and clobber around
vCenter at all after you set it up so
when she provision a user cluster this
piece is all automated we're leveraging
data stores on the backend we have a few
different data stores SSD HDD we're also
leveraging persistent storage which
we'll talk about a little bit but as far
as this goes it looks a lot like any
other cluster we're leveraging a
template to be able to spin up the base
node before it gets bootstrapped we've
got a bunch of different data stores
we've got some different virtual
switches there's a lot of flexibility on
how that stuff's configured and we've
just put everything in a resource group
to keep it separate so no reason why you
couldn't use a shared cluster that you
already have to get this up and running
clearly we need to be able to call the
API and orchestrate a lot of these
capabilities another piece that's part
of this is we are using an f5 virtual
appliance to do all the ingress pieces
and that's also orchestrated so if you
do carve out and ingress inside of the
environment it will use the container
container connector piece that ephod
provides to carve out these we're going
to show a demo of how we're able to do
that dynamically near the end so it's
able to you know orchestrate all the
front-end I know Wes there's always lots
of questions around ingress networking
and some stuff that's coming you want to
comment on and some of the stuff that's
coming down there yeah so one of the
common questions we get is what's the
dependency on f5 so for we really wanted
that out of box experience where you
could use kubernetes to provision load
balancers support right out of the box
but we have heard from customers that
they already are running things like hea
procs here engine X instead of f5 so one
of the things we are gonna be adding
pretty soon is going to be the ability
to bring your own load balancer and plug
into that I think longer term you'll
start to see maybe a Google provided
load balancer out of the box but we're
just we're kind of listening to the
customer feedback around some of these
hard dependencies or I have different
environments already in there
so you can see here that we are looking
at the user cluster if you look in the
top right partition we also have the
admin cluster as we extend more cart or
more clusters you'll get more part
obviously so these are the base ones you
can see there's an sto space we've got
our virtual server list has been
populated through when we were plumbing
these pieces we've been playing around
with connait container connector a
little bit there we that we can put f5
in the SDN range and skip the whole node
port piece so that's something we're
looking at doing and then introducing
other load balancers and things like
that yeah I think one other thing you
know from the application provider
perspective that we're coming from you
know it's critical that we don't want to
be in the entire infrastructure business
right we want to be able to go in and
fit into the environment that the
customer is in and so the ability to
take advantage of a private cloud like
this and put some standard in
implementation on top of it like gke and
then us be able to just leverage that
and go in and take advantage of that and
take advantage of the infrastructure
that the customers already built to me
that's a critical value out here that
that this is shown to be pretty
successful at okay so Wes talked about
the connector and where you manage this
from so not everybody is a goober
Nettie's expert not everybody wants to
be running cube Caudill commands so we
can leverage Google cloud platforms
admin station or web UI to be able to
look at all our clusters and start to
see what's going on with them and diving
into the details so I showed you earlier
the node list this is the exact same
view through here and you'll be able to
see you get quite a bit of insight into
what's going on into here we're gonna
show some stackdriver integration and
stuff like that but if you look at our
cluster here's our cluster there's no
reason why we couldn't have other
regions that are cloud-based in here the
whole idea is it's a common experience
across your on-prem and your cluster
inside the cloud yeah now really is
critical to that hybrid strategy we're
talking about that if you can have the
same point of control and management
visibility to both your on-prem and the
stuff you start to move into the cloud
then it just becomes so much easier to
make that move yeah one of the things
that I hear a lot and I heard it from
Dan too is is these enterprise customers
who are trying to train their IT staff
and their developers to think more like
the cloud well this is that bridge where
you can start to use a lot of the tool
in but you can
operate it in on-prem yeah so we'll look
through the obviously there's gonna be
more components added to this but we can
look at all our pods so you know usually
you're trying to cube CL described pod
get the pod name you can really drill
down through it all through here
and you can see what what store just
using you can see any events you can
also look at the amel configuration so
this is a big piece of I think what
people are looking for as far as a
managed solution is having the toolkit
to be able to have manage upgrades and
manage the lifecycle of my clusters be
able to provision pieces through there
we're working pretty hard to build a lot
of the CI CD toolkit into this workflow
and be able to use a lot of Google
toolkits that we were comfortable with
using in cloud and leverage them on Prem
as well so I mentioned storage here's
all the PBS
everyone says applications that move to
kubernetes don't need state that's we
always find out they need state about an
hour into the discussion so there's
quite a few PV requirements in this
environment and we'll dive into that you
can see all the config maps and
configuration secrets are obviously
protected you need an elevated account
to be able to go in and look at any of
that stuff anything you want to say
about just the experience wes around
managing this stuff and leveraging some
of the other tools yeah so you know I I
think the the long-term vision for this
is that all of those cloud services that
you were mentioning so cloud build cloud
hosted spinnaker deployments doing
policy management side the cloud as well
these are the pieces that we want to
have run in the cloud environment but be
able to access these these clusters and
so for the most part we want this to
feel
I think Kyle said it best he's like this
is an extension of your region right
it's just running in a different
location you know I think long term you
know let's say over the next couple
years we'll start to see more things
where we have let's say global load
balancers that can maybe route traffic
intelligently through clusters running
in these various environments so there's
a really cool long-term story about how
we can have this brain that can
federated to these different
environments great so stat drivers
integrated we can get metrics and logs
into
GCP right from the cluster's west
mention some of the other toolkit we
deployed so we deployed Cystic really
early we knew that we needed to test
this at scale and we wanted to get a
really good baseline so it was a good
way to start from nothing with no load
and then ramp the load up and really get
into the network stack and see what was
going so we've created some base
dashboards now the nice part is we've
got a good baseline we can really start
ramping up the load till this thing
starts to fall down and really learn
where we need to scale it we can dive
right into the network view really we're
looking at every single system call
across all microservices and we can
drill down to see the length of time and
what's exactly happening in it so
getting these bit these dashboards in
place really sets us up for future
success as we start to tune this yeah
and one of the things that you'll find
as you start to try to move a legacy app
to be cloud native is that so you're
gonna decompose out you're gonna break
it into little pieces and all of the
learnings that you had before still
relevant but you're gonna find out that
you have new bottlenecks or you know
maybe things aren't quite connecting the
way you used to think they were and so
having these kind of tools in here to be
able to go down and drill down and find
out where your problems are where your
new bottlenecks are what kind of
performance are getting that's critical
to the assess of projects and and this
really helped us out because we did run
into a few issues where we were either
under provisioned or had made some bad
choices in terms of configuration and we
were easily able to come back and figure
out what the problem was and address it
pretty easy yeah so it's just deployed
as a daemon set on all the nodes will
probably wait for questions but oh it's
Cystic so sis takes a SAS tool
monitoring analytics tool that's really
focused on containers so it's capturing
every system call essentially and and
it's got a whole analytics engine the
nice part is the dashboard so you know
being able to graph data and look at it
over time and saying why did it get slow
and drilling down that's what we really
used it for so helped us aggregate all
those logs and things like that no
problem so I mentioned Harbor
so harbors a CNC F project we're a CNC F
member so we wanted to avoid having to
pull container images down every time we
built them over the the pipe that Teva
has up to GC P so we deployed hard
whereas a container to look after the
registry components so we have a sink
job when their build process runs we can
pull the containers down to the local
land and then we're more building and
deploying the applications via the home
templates we're just pulling off the
local network so Harbor was a nice
little registry to use really easy to
get up and running no reason why you
couldn't leverage artifact tree or some
enterprise registry that you're already
using today this is just the way we sell
it for this project yeah and this is
another sort of enterprise specific
thing you know if you're gonna try to
take this approach to do this with your
application obviously you know there's a
high sensitivity to churn and being able
to prequalify things in the customer
environment so having the ability to
stage like this and then try things out
in parallel that's a huge strength of
this that you wouldn't necessarily get
in a traditional environment where you'd
have to build up an entire parallel
system yeah so I think we have around
I think there's upwards of 60 or 80
images that were leveraging in this so
everybody's always interested in storage
so we thought we'd cover a little bit on
the storage side natively the default
storage provider for GK today is a
vSphere cloud provider so essentially
what that does is allows you to
dynamically provision volumes
block-based volumes via the platform so
what it's doing is a dynamically carving
out a VMDK on the back end and attaching
it to the host and then providing that
access back to the container so we
leverage this for anything that needed
persistent storage there is a NFS
provider that has rwx we didn't have
time to test that yet it's something
we're definitely looking at doing other
pieces that we're looking to test as we
move forward our more cloud native
storage options so we did some testing
of rook which is another CN CF project
but we're looking at things like robin
and port works a lot of customers are
leveraging like a back-end NetApp
appliance but they have a Triton plugin
that you can leverage so storages is
what's nice about it if you don't know
kubernetes very well is it's very very
pluggable all the components are
pluggable you could run multiple storage
options here and the way they work and
we'll show you in a little bit is it's
just a default storage class or you have
different storage classes you may
a storage class for SSD a storage class
for HDD and you can put policies and
rules and quotas and stuff around that
so I'll show you how easy it is anybody
again if you're not familiar kubernetes
and you've been asking for volumes in a
vm world you know change record wait go
by the guy coffee the idea behind all
this stuff is it's all very declarative
so all you have to do to carve a storage
out in this environment is this simple
yamo configuration I run that I
immediately get a pv created and then in
a couple minutes I'll end up getting
that ready so you know we've got a 2 gig
volume ready to go for me to leverage my
application literally takes a couple
seconds what you'll see now is we call
using gub C we're calling the vSphere
API you can see it's carved out the VM
decays on the back end for us and that's
just leveraging a regular data store
that you would leverage in your VMware
environment nothing special just need
the plug-in so we'll just go ahead and
delete the PV you can see the PV is gone
we'll call B Center again and there's
nothing left so that's just a look at
storage storage this is something that
like I said everyone thinks all these
kubernetes workloads are ephemeral
they're generally not there's a lot of
stuff that does need State so there's
lots of good storage providers out there
that we can leverage next we're gonna
talk about auto scaling a little bit
auto scaling seems to be a conversation
that I have with every customer and we
always have lots of religious debates on
what they really want but Optio really
has a business case for this and it's
built into their platform so dan you
want to talk about just the advantages
and why you guys feel it's so important
and what it does for you sure so in the
telecom business especially calling for
example or even data it tends to be very
cyclical so both across the day you can
see cycles as well as across the year so
you know first thing in the morning you
might have a spike in calls or on a
certain holiday you might have a spike
in call so if you look at this chart
that we have here that's what that wavy
curve is a sine wave kind of thing and
you know you also tend to have some kind
of long-term trend in terms of growth or
you might even have
long-term trend hopefully not but you
might have to long-term trying to drop
of traffic and so if you look at that
step line there that's traditionally how
you have dealt with it in a hardware
bare-metal kind of environment you have
to predict in advance you have to over
provision if you under provision then
you get that little red triangle which
means you've just failed your
application on a probably pretty regular
basis people are dropping calls and if
you're way down there below the blue
line then your your over provision
you're paying for a bunch of hardware to
generate heat so it's really critical
for our business and there's a lot of
other businesses like this that have
these kind of patterns and so if we can
in in the public cloud this is a
no-brainer right you can provision VMs
in the background but even in a in a
private cloud environment if you have
shared infrastructure with a little bit
of additional capacity or you're trying
to do some testing or even you have a
say of a special holiday that you need
to pre provision for this scenario can
take advantage of that those the auto
scaling capabilities that we have in gke
and also in our application so that
you're not wasting a lot of hardware and
you are able to adapt as you need to go
so we're gonna show when Dan and I first
talked to one of the big things we
wanted success criteria was let's get to
the point where we can auto scale so the
discussion went well pods are somewhat
easy their application can scale in
cloud you know Google's got tons of
capacity so that part problem is pretty
easy to solve but in the VMware world we
need to have capacity and essentially
another node is another VM so we can
orchestrate and automate that since the
whole platform is declarative as we
talked about is it was pretty doable
we've done some work with configuration
manager to be able to do this more in a
get-ups fashion so that everything would
be source of truth and get you do a pull
request change a node count gets
approved automatically goes it spins up
the cluster so we'll show you the
capability of that we've also we're
putting out a blog I think later today
that demos that and but you can see here
we have 11 nodes running and what this
is this OCS process is essentially the
the workers that are processing all the
the call volume and doing all the
analytics and all the billing so it can
only handle so much load and Tevas
application when it gets under certain
conditions it knows how to scale up so
we're gonna go through the use case and
you can see here we're using graph Anna
and Prometheus on the backend that's
part of their application so the green
represents calls per second so this test
we got up to about 60,000 calls per
second with this environment the blue
line represents number of pods that are
running so we're generally running that
one pod that I showed you
but once load comes up we need to scale
to two and then beyond
if we keep cranking it up so if you look
at these graphs you can see we were
upwards of thirty thousand transactions
here we scaled downs for our pod scaled
back down so this is pod level scaling
in kubernetes working off metrics we're
pushing about ten thousand a second at
this point in time so this stuff's
fairly out of the box and you can see we
ran a lot of tests and we were pushing
load dropping load pushing load dropping
load so you can see it's very
consistently scaling up and scaling down
and our error rates are almost nothing
we're be able to handle the load up
Tevas got a nice little load generator
for us so they built a great little tool
that we can go in and just slide the bar
so we'll jump it up to about 40,000 a
second right now the nice part is we're
leveraging prometheus on the back end
everything's real-time on the graph so
you can see their software has said okay
kubernetes says let's spin up another
pod with three more containers to handle
this
so load goes up pretty quickly and we're
pod scales - - or starts to bring all
the containers up and Dan mentioned that
red line in your in his diagram earlier
so we're up to 40,000 the red lines
representing our error rate is starting
to go up because as I showed you earlier
we were pushing the cluster from a
resource perspective pretty hard with
our with our five nodes and our 1111
nodes on the back side but here you can
represent now the second pod is running
here just one comment I mean the scaling
we're doing here is this is a nice thing
that once again if you're not that
familiar the kubernetes I mean this is
just a standard autoscaler based on CPU
you can
do a lot more elaborate things and we're
looking at implementing those in the
future but getting something like this
working in kubernetes and in this
environment is is not rocket science
right so if you if you build structured
your application properly so that the
pieces can be independently run and
scaled in containers then it's pretty
straightforward to just build yourself
autoscaler in there that can handle that
based on CP load for example so we've
scaled the load back down so things are
gonna start behaving again cuz it's
gonna match the capacity of there we
need you'll see that kubernetes is
terminating that other pods we don't
need it anymore now we're back down to
one load we're back down to a standard
processing now obviously the issue with
that use case was we didn't have enough
nodes on the back end so we have to
solve the node scaling problem so that
we can solve the pod scaling problem and
everything in GK i mentioned is
declarative sowest you want to comment
on just the approach of how you built
the automation and why you built it the
way it did yeah so a lot of the
architecture for GK and Prem is based
off of something in the open source we
were working we've been working on
called the cluster API and what it
allows you to do is define the shape of
your cluster the kubernetes version
add-ons you want to install and then you
can also define the nodes so you can
define what what images you're going to
deploy on them what kubernetes
components are running on those and what
Kyle's going to show here is like
scaling at this point is really just a
simple matter of going and changing the
node count from 11 to 12 checking that
into a git repository and then the
cluster is looking for these changes
syncing them down and then it's just a
matter of our machinery going in saying
hey I noticed a change I need to move
from 11 to 12 let's go and bump the the
cluster up and the the really nice thing
about this is you know where you'll
probably hear the term like cluster is
cattle we're gonna start moving down
this direction where you can have these
you know portable metadata environments
that describe your clusters and you can
spin these up in different locations
really quickly but the source of truth
is all in a git repo it's all
declarative and you can put linters
around that you can put change request
validation and things like that super
nice way to deploy and manage clusters
so I positive or a second the bottom
right hand corner is us monitoring the
vCenter API
so you see I we saved the file in the
top left automatically we've got the
center API picking up that that changed
the declarative nature and we'll flip
over to B Center in a second you're
gonna see that the nodes are
automatically coming up and they're
gonna get added to the cluster so you
see here on the bottom we're powering on
the VM from template within a very short
period of time the node comes up you can
see it's up we don't have an IP address
yet but it's gonna get an IP address
very quickly and it's gonna join the
cluster and now we've got an extra node
in the cluster so you see on the bottom
left we've got our node online now it's
been on for one second it's not ready
it's it's bootstrapping
and that'll change pretty quickly and be
able to come on to a ready state one of
the interesting things that we found out
early is opt IVA in gke makes a couple
kernel tweaks to their to their nodes so
we had never really tested that so it
was good to know that we actually could
make those tweaks that they needed that
they had in cloud so top right corner we
just solved this currently with an
ansible playbook so we wrote an ID
potent ansible playbook we just you know
add to the inventory file run it it'll
automatically make them the kernel tweak
reboot the host and now the nodes a
first-class citizen in the cluster plan
on this is since the we have a VM
template what we're going to do is just
put it into the template and then we
won't need the ansible playbook to run
so it'll just be spun into the template
I know this could be kind of hard to see
for folks in the back but well we'll
publish this online and also have a blog
post that goes into a lot more these
details yeah so in this case we're just
this is just straight-up ansible we're
running it against the node the nodes
gonna take the change you can see it
skipped all the ones that we've already
made the change - no - well go not ready
and then it's really fast within a 20 30
seconds the node comes back up and what
you'll find is when I describe the node
we've automatically deployed all the
daemon sets so we have a Cystic demon
set we've got a bunch of different human
sets that are running for the
environment that we need and now we'll
get to the point where let's you know
let's scale this up even higher and
let's see how it performs this time from
a narrow perspective so we pump it up to
60 mm
transactions per second you can
immediately see the graph Anna
dashboards are gonna ramp up we're gonna
get our second pod scaled and we don't
have a lot of errors because we've got
the right capacity to be able to handle
handle the volume so having these load
generators and loads tests we're just
really critical for us to be able to
actually test this stuff trial and error
some different tweaks and settings and
having a really good monitoring set I've
allowed us to kind of get the baseline
of that um so two other quick things to
show you we're gonna everyone's
wondering why haven't they talked about
the networking yet so we'll talk about
networking quickly Wes do you want to
comment just generally on the networking
strategy and yeah so to the so the way
we've we've architected the the
footprint of GG on prem is that each
cluster is an island so they form an
eyepiece or mesh in between them but
everything that is connected to outside
the cluster has to get in at it out we
are using BGP so we do have a
theoretical like 1500 max for a lot of
these cluster sizes that we started out
up but we're gonna expand this over time
and yeah we use calico for a network
policy I already was talked about f5 we
used that for the l floor a load
balancer where we can actually go and
spin up service type load balancer and
have that route traffic into it and
eventually we will have the ability to
make that plop public pluggable so you
can actually go and bring in a different
load balance or service in there so I
mentioned you know how hard it is to
carve storage we all know how hard it is
to get a rule put into your f5 box and
how many tickets and coffees that takes
this is if you're not familiar
kubernetes it's kind of the same thing
we just run a simple cube cuddle command
we've got a famous beer giffy app that
we've just deployed there we've also
created the endpoint this is the entire
configuration of the endpoint this
integrates into f5 so all of this is
sending api calls you can see we go back
to our f5 we're in the user space we
don't have we've got four endpoints if i
refresh we automatically get our default
ingress if we go look at that you can
see we've got a cluster IP we're
leveraging if we go to our application
that we just deployed we've got our
random beer giffy up and running in a
matter of seconds so um so that's it for
the demo side maybe we'll flip back to
the slides and
close out so tips and lessons learned
everyone's probably interested on that I
think we can all make a few comments
this environment sizings
you know important we knew this was a
big application when we first started
with four nodes we got the application
out but we were like rate at the edge of
leveraging amount of CPU and memory that
we needed so opti would be in a very
agile team this cluster is actually
deployed in Berlin we were able to get
another node added to it and we're able
to keep the project moving so you know
make sure you size your environment we
got into a few interesting issues that
we need to look into is when we were
pushing load heavy against pods that had
PV requirements
DRS was starting to do more than it
should've and started moving
environments around so we decided to
disable DRS for a lot of these
environments we really didn't need it
needs stuff moving around you know I
mentioned monitoring tools getting all
that stuff in place early so you have a
good baseline anything else you guys
want to add to the yeah I mean one of
the things I think is a natural tendency
is to wait on spend a lot of time
thinking about your operational model
before you do this right a lot of people
try to try it out and see what happens
and and I think that you know it's it's
really critical especially jumping into
new environment like this to really
think about your operational model and
things like what type of monitoring you
need to put in place what do you want to
monitor
you know who's getting access to that
that kind of stuff I think the other
really cool thing about this it was we
already alluded to this but you know we
had already spent the time to move our
app to gke in the cloud but I was
expecting a lot more work in terms of
refactoring our scripts in terms of
deployment and things like that to get
this to work and yet we pretty minimal
amount of work there so that's a really
nice thing so if you're gonna invest the
time in here I think the the promise of
GK on Prem relative to the cloud
it's definitely delivering on that so
yeah other pieces I would mention is you
know put some time into your deployment
see ICD deployment strategies Activa had
done a really good job so there was a
couple times when we tested some weird
things and we wanted to start from a
clean slate again
and that you know that was an
hour-and-a-half effort to go and
redeploy their entire application after
we built the the new cluster which was
maybe a 4050 minute exercise because
we've automated a lot of it so it gave
us a clean slate again and if we saw
weird things happening because we were
experimenting we didn't have to
troubleshoot and wonder if that was
causing something we just repaved the
infrastructure let's just rebuild it and
let's start from a clean slate again so
this cluster got built
Sunday night again and then we did this
demo last night so we're really
comfortable at standing it up and
rebuilding it again other things to
think about is dan mentioned to do but
leveraging helm charts and just you know
spending an extra couple hours writing
that ansible playbook saved us a lot of
time down the road so when we had to
build the cluster we didn't have to SSH
into eleven VMs and go and do the kernel
parameter so just roll up your sleeves
you know do some google searching most
of the informations out that reach out
to us we'll share some of these play
books and stuff that we've figured out
along the way and the only other thing I
would say is we did a stand-up every day
with the team and everybody showed up to
it some days it was just a chat but it
also removed any roadblocks and kept
everybody really in the loop which was
going on so being a distributed team and
not seeing each other all the time we
had eleven o'clock stand-up every day
and it really helped the project move
forward and and I helped us get rid of
any roadblocks and also provided good
updates to the stakeholders because we
had a pretty short runway to get all
this ready for next oh yeah I would say
and it's probably give you a lot of
questions we'll be at the booth a lot
you can also you know find us on Twitter
you like email us we'll figure out how
to get in touch and answer those
questions for you and I guess the
closing thing is just if you guys liked
this talk go and give us some feedback
and we'll be around
[Music]